yeah was [ __ ] raining on this is one
thing I've learned that when you go to a
football game and you're dealing with
the elements this is the more of a
douchebag you look like the warmer
you're gonna be alright
I saw the rain and I said [ __ ] this and
we went right to Dick's Sporting Goods
and I'm like I'm buying that [ __ ] I'm
gonna buy a raincoat with the matching
raincoat slacks I don't give a [ __ ] I
bought a pair of wool socks and I was
good to go
so I'm with virzi and you know they only
had like two raincoats left and they
were the exact same color
this [ __ ] grape slush puppy purple so
we both have matching extra-large
[ __ ] joy we got the jacket and the
pants like we're working at a [ __ ]
airport and we're bringing in the
[ __ ] soul plane right that was a
purple airplane right that's what we
look like so we show up to the game
right neither one of us is comfortable
because neither one of us is a jets or
Bills fan so we're in enemy territory
and it's [ __ ] drizzling it out it's
[ __ ] cold so I proceeded to put on
this barny the dinosaur outfit right and
right off the bat virzi starts punking
out going man I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna wear that I'm just gonna wear the
top I'm just gonna wear the top trying
to act like it's not raining out that
bad the reality is is he didn't want to
go through the hazing that he would have
to if the two of us walked in with our
purple on purple [ __ ] raincoats times
two we would have got a ton of [ __ ] and
I was prepared to take it I Adam and I
had a whole [ __ ] silly walk I was
gonna be doing I don't give a [ __ ] so he
punked out so we end up walking in but
my head's cold right all I have is a
baseball cap on so I'm like [ __ ] I gotta
buy a hat can I buy a bills who gives a
[ __ ] they were last place male by a
Bills hat and I saw this this one with
the Patriot logo on it I said [ __ ]
I'll get that one so I put that one on
I'm nice and warm we go to will call we
pick up our tickets we go into that high
school football stadium that they have
out there that I actually love
looks like an old school football
stadium you know what about that
football stadium that's about the size
of a football stadium that holds real
fans you know what I mean all these
these new ones that hold like a hundred
thousand [ __ ] pets all the bandwagon
[ __ ] you know when you're owing for
the real [ __ ] fans show up or one
three right so we walk into the goddamn
stadium we're lovin life right I'm
already laughing at Bercy cuz I know
damn well what's gonna happen he's gonna
walk out there there's gonna be some
shitty little plastic seat that's gonna
be covered in [ __ ] water and the only
way he's gonna be able to absorb it is
through his goddamn jeans and his
[ __ ] BVDs and then he's gonna be
sitting there where they'll wrinkled up
nutsack that's gonna be getting
hypothermia by second quarter why do I
know this because I've been there so we
get a couple of beers we get this
[ __ ] beef on a stick or whatever the
[ __ ] they call it we're good to go we go
in there sit down
he sits basically down in a [ __ ]
puddle he tried to stick a newspaper
down which is very absorbent and I don't
know we sat there and I had hope for
about eight seconds in that game and the
Jets came down and just [ __ ] did they
just kick the [ __ ] out of him
Christ they kicked his [ __ ] out of them
and it was just over so weak so
immediately our solution is just to
start drinking the way we drank at the
Masters we'll like [ __ ] it let's let's
let's get going here right so we'll make
a trip after trip and all of a sudden I
got to take a piss right so I go and I'm
standing in line and all of a sudden
this dis [ __ ] six-foot-five
goofy-looking jackass one of those guys
who's like six foot five but you still
think he can take him cuz he's just
covered in baby fat you know he's got a
couple of whiskers on his chin and his
cheeks are rosy er than st. Nick right
he's got this jersey on and this big
stupid I'm a Buffalo Bills fan with the
horns on it and stuff you know he's the
wacky guy so I'm not even thinking [ __ ]
right this is Bill's jets I don't have a
dog in this fight I'm not talking any
[ __ ] I'm fine
I forgot
I was wearing my Patriots hat and all of
a sudden this big goofy jackass starts
going what's what you had with your
Patriots fan he liked the rats we got a
rat away the rats he likes the [ __ ]
rat this [ __ ] right and I'm like yeah
you know whatever he starts giving me
[ __ ] I start giving him [ __ ] back and
then the weirdest [ __ ] thing happened
I by the time I get in to the actual
men's room I've talked I've given these
people so much [ __ ] [ __ ] that
actually there's bills and Jets fans at
a builds and Jets game they're playing
each other they stop giving each other
[ __ ] and they teamed up together and
started giving me [ __ ] right and then I
just said I don't know what I was
thinking I felt like I was on stage
because it was like a crowd I wasn't
thinking like hey you know what Bill you
really haven't had a fight outside of
your family since maybe planes [ __ ]
street hockey in the sixth grade I
didn't give a [ __ ] I'm in a goddamn
bathroom waiting to take a piss and a
goddamn trough by the way and and then
they just started giving up [ __ ] this
one dude suck on Tom Brady sucks dick he
sucks dick and he's like miming it like
ridiculously well so I'm like eh you
know buddy you do that real well because
I learned it by watching Tom Brady
Michael yeah did you rent that porno you
[ __ ] [ __ ] gets a little uglier gets a
little uglier than this other dude what
the [ __ ] did OD I came out what the hell
he was saying to me and I just said look
I'm sorry you guys have never won a
Super Bowl
you know then the Jets fan pipes in I go
do you realize the last time you guys
want a Super Bowl Charlie Chaplin was
still alive do you understand that do
you know what cars look like the last
time you won you [ __ ] morons and then
then this other guy go dude we've won
three Super Bowls I'm sorry right and
then the guy goes woo you didn't play in
the games I go neither did you then he's
just staying in with his dumb look on
his face I go that's right keep staring
four with you got nothing forgetting
that I don't know how to fight
so all of a sudden it's my turn to piss
I take my dick out I'm ready to piss and
one of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
push me in the back
hoping that I was pissing at the time
fortunately I wasn't so I turn around I
put my dick away cuz I'm a gentleman I
said I goes out how you guys do it out
here really I go which one you guys push
me like I'm gonna [ __ ] like I'm [ __ ]
Jackie Chan and for some reason none of
them said anything I don't know if it
was my purple on purple raincoat or the
look of fire in my eye but I'm a [ __ ]
42 year old balding redhead talking [ __ ]
in there and none of them said anything
so now it's kind of funny to me I felt
like I was in like the World Series of
Poker and I went all-in and I and I
didn't have a hand whatsoever so I don't
know who the [ __ ] pushed me but that's
what I mean come on
bitchiest move of the [ __ ] week how
do you do that how do you do that how do
you how do you push another man when
he's got his goddamn dick out trying to
piss into a [ __ ] trough I mean how do
you get lower than that do you guys have
any ideas how do you get lower than that
so then after none of them said anything
I go back and I start taking a piss and
then that other dude who was miming
somebody sucking a dick unbelievably
well right next to me weird one of those
stupid hats that has the toggles on the
side and he's still trying to give me
[ __ ] and I'm gonna go [ __ ] yourself and
then he just starts screaming over and
over again are you looking at my dick
are you looking at my dick like
maniacally like five times I just sort
of stared at him like why do you keep
going this this gay angle like why is
there always uh I don't know I think he
was one of those guys he was kind of in
the closet and then so he just goes to
football games and he gets really drunk
trying to just kill the feelings that I
think he liked me is what I'm saying so
if he's listening to this I'm sorry I'm
spoken for you [ __ ] pansy you [ __ ]
believe that first of all what's wrong
with me
I really replayed all of that in my head
cuz once I got out of there I was like I
really started thinking like what what
did you think you were gonna do in there
they're not Clint Eastwood yet saying
things Clint Eastwood would say what
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you dude I
don't know if I've said this before in a
podcast a public bathroom
is the worst [ __ ] place to ever get
into a fight there is nothing soft
there's everything is porcelain pipes
that concrete floor and then it has a
mist of piss and [ __ ] it's just a
[ __ ] it's the worst it's the worst
place ever you know not to mention it
usually starts evidently when one person
has begun the pissing process so you
know older a little bit wiser so then
I'm standing in line to go get some more
alcohol cuz God knows that's what you
need after an incident like that and I
was just kind of just sitting there
thinking like alright No how should I
have played that it should have ended
when the dude with the water buffalo hat
started giving me [ __ ] what I should
have done was roll with it I should you
like the Patriots I should have been
like yeah you know you guys scored
thirty on us last week man you guys look
great man I bet the Jets I mean I bet
against the Jets I hope you guys should
have just ended it with that ended it I
should have I should have extended an
olive branch that's what I should have
done in the future that's what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna do because that was a that was
a potentially ugly situation but
fortunately I think the people who were
doing it you know had jobs and no one
wanted to get sued and no one was
willing to take it to that level and
when I say fortunately I mean for me in
my face do you know how bad that would
have been to get stomped in that [ __ ]
purple on purple raincoat laying there
with my dirty [ __ ] Patriots that and
my team wasn't even playing I would have
lost the lawsuit they wouldn't man let
me get this straight you're a Patriots
fan you were a Patriots head to a Bills
Jets game and you somehow managed to get
the [ __ ] kicked out of you what the [ __ ]
did you say you know that's one of the
great things about being a guy is you
actually have to
responsibility for your for your action
see what would be like there's no excuse
there's no reason I don't care what
happened you don't hit a girl which is
true you don't hit a [ __ ] girl but
there's no learning in that there's no
lesson you know even my best friends
would have been like yeah those guys are
[ __ ] [ __ ] in the butt you know
there would have been an awkward pause I
don't being like dude what the [ __ ] you
talking [ __ ] for by yourself at a game
when your team isn't even [ __ ]
playing what's wrong with you
you're 42 years old get your [ __ ]
together and they would have been right